Vanessa Carlysle stole Wade Wilson's
heart in the 2016 here to Deadpool
what's a nice place like you doin in the
girl like this and the actress who
played her Morena Baccarin stole viewers
hearts along the way backer ins been
appearing in hit properties since 2001
so you might feel like you've seen her
before especially if you're a sci-fi fan
but it may be hard to figure out exactly
where he is why Vanessa from Deadpool
looks so familiar way off Broadway
backer ins first leading role came in
the small film way off-broadway in which
she played a young actress trying to
make it in New York City
her character Rebecca was one of a group
of friends are struggling to find a way
to turn their artistic ventures while
also dealing with her own personal
anguish
although the drama wasn't seen by many
they earned mostly good reviews with
backer ins performance in particular
being singled out for praise Firefly in
what probably still her most well-known
small screen role Baccarin played Inara
on Joss Whedon's short-lived series
Firefly for many of the plans storylines
surrounding the carrots were cut short
when the series was canceled after just
14 episodes
Inara was a fan favorite for her poised
charisma and intelligence
despite Firefly short run the series
became a cult hit and years after being
cancelled it was brought back for a
feature film serenity in which Baccarin
reprised her role The OC it might take a
hardcore fan of The OC to remember much
about Matt Ramsey sandy Cohen's partner
during his 10 year as the lead of the
Newport group Matz had a brief love
interest in backer and Maya Griffin the
daughter of Sandy's rival Henry although
Baccarin only showed up in three
episodes of the series her appearance is
still notable it's where she met her
future Gotham co-star and fiance Ben
McKenzie who starred as Ryan Atwood on
the series it wasn't love at first sight
for the two though in fact McKenzie has
said he doesn't remember seeing Baccarin
on set and a thought he was meeting her
for the first time when they reunited on
Gotham awkward How I Met Your Mother
Baccarin only appeared on one episode of
How I Met Your Mother but it was an
important one
her character arrived drawing Marshall
and Lily's season to break up with
Baccarin starring as Chloe the only
woman Marshall actually dates during the
brief separation while Chloe didn't get
a happy ending she'll always be
remembered for her crazy eyes and
pushing the show's main couple back
together
stargate sg1 with firefly Baccarin
developed a following in the sci-fi
community one she expanded with her next
few roles her first step back into genre
fare came in stargate sg1 the actress
played the villainous Adria for five
episodes of the series and briefly
reprised the role in the movie stargates
the arc of truth in addition to serving
as a next big sci-fi role Stargate was
also back Erin's first real chance to
play a villain aside should explore in
some of her later roles V backer ins
next big role also involved playing a
sci-fi bad guy but this time in the ABC
series V the revival of the high concept
80s TV hit featured Baccarin as Anna the
queen of an invading alien species
Baccarin earned multiple Saturn Award
nominations and a scream Award
nomination for her work unfortunately
the series was plagued by low ratings
and high production costs and was
cancelled before it could reach a third
season guest starring roles like many
actors Baccarin has made the guest
starring rounds on TV appearing on shows
like Heartland numbers medium and The
Good Wife in addition to a multi-episode
arc on the Mentalist as a murderous
matchmaker super fans of It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia may also recognize
Baccarin from the show's unaired pilot
in which she played the transgendered
Carmen Baccarin said she appeared in the
episode because she was college friends
with writer and star Glenn Howerton but
she unfortunately wasn't able to
continue with the series due to other
commitments homeland Baccarin earned an
Emmy nomination for her homeland
performance as Nick's wife Jessica
appearing consistently throughout the
series first and second series although
she became less of a staple in season 3
due to her real-life pregnancy jessica
was written off the show before the
fourth season opening her up for other
projects where her character got a
little better treatment
still despite the fact that fans didn't
enjoy her character Baccarin
demonstrated her dramatic chops and
earned a major award nomination to boot
back in the day making the jump to
big-screen comedies in 2014
Baccarin starred and back in the day
created by and co-starring Smallville's
Michael Rosenbaum the movies tone didn't
go over well with critics with the film
amassing a terrible 11% on Rotten
Tomatoes fortunately it didn't
completely sink back Erin's comedy Korea
spy backer ins rebound came in the form
of spy a hit comedy that sits at a much
more impressive 94 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes in the movie Baccarin plays
Karen Walker the perfect super spy and
the rival to Melissa McCarthy Susan a
solid comedy showcase for Baccarin spy
was also one of her most notable pre
Deadpool big-screen roles
proving the TV star could work in a
big-budget blockbuster Gotham before
Deadpool Baccarin took on the role of
another beloved comic book character
portraying dr. Leslie Thompkins on Fox's
Gotham her on-screen love story with Jim
Gordon has spilled over into real life
and she and Ben McKenzie got engaged in
2016 shortly after the birth of their
daughter Baccarin says Lee's pregnancy
on Gotham wasn't at all related to her
own though just a happy coincidence
let's hope their real-life romance goes
better than it does on Gotham thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to